over the last few weeks there have been
three churches in a single parish of
Louisiana parish is analogous to
counties and other states three African
America store ik black churches that
have been burned down just in the last
few weeks the churches are all historic
all over a hundred years old and we'll
put a couple pictures on the screen as
you can see the churches were burned to
the ground now there was a fourth Church
that was in another Parish Louisiana
parish it was about two hundred miles
away and that particular church they
don't know if that one is connected to
these three but the three that have been
connected in the same county they have
all are the three that have burned down
in the same parish they are believed to
be connected and a possible hate crime
it's something that two things that are
happening the same time in my mind which
is why I'm hesitating are it's two
things that this seems to be a trend of
historically of attacking the black
community of racism and hate crimes
happening in the black community
targeting african-american churches
because of just the historic nature of
the world that black churches have
played black churches generally have
been historically it may not be the case
now but particularly during the civil
rights movement they were the
cornerstone of the civil rights movement
they were the the hotbed of radicalism
in the black community that if there was
a fight to be had you often confined
some of the biggest fighters coming from
the church obviously the first one that
comes to mind for most everyone is dr.
King and so it has always seemed
historically the bombing the bombing
that killed four little black girls
during the civil rights movement the
bombing of a church even recently we saw
mother Emanuel AME being targeted by
Dylan roof killing nine parishioners of
that church it just the reason this sets
off so many alarms is because
historically
white supremacist and white nationalists
have targeted the black church and so
with four churches burning down in
Louisiana three of them burning down in
a single parish it's believed that this
is a hate crime that's that that's first
but you also have to look at the other
side of this the general uptick in white
supremacist right wing violence in this
country we've seen an uptick since the
election of Donald Trump there's just no
question there's there's tangible data
evidence to show that the rise of white
nationalism and white supremacist
violence in this country coincided with
our the resurgence not the rise let me
correct myself the resurgence in white
supremacist violence in this country
coincided with the election of Donald
Trump and and it should be no surprise
we see that conservatism in this country
has time and again then the excuse and
the intellectual veneer that's placed on
top of hate that's placed on top of
white supremacy that's placed on top of
policies that we see that are trying to
be implemented at the border even now
and so there's a direct line connecting
all of these things the type of hate
that we're seeing the type of violence
that we're seeing in this Louisiana
parish burning down of historic black
churches the burning down of historic
black churches being connected and tied
to actions of this administration that
absolutely the language you cannot sever
the language of Donald Trump from the
uptick in right-wing white nationalist
violence in this country